a lot of people have credited you for uh
Andrew Tate choosing to remove all of
his content from uh social media
willingly willingly he willingly went
away yeah you guys had one debate and
then after that apparently he removed
everything
how did you make that happen like what
was that the goal or was it just
discourse like really break that down
like I wanted
I'm bummed because I wanted to like
actually talk to him about the sex
trafficking [ __ ] you know what I mean
like because that's like way more
interesting and way more awful than like
just running another Tai Lopez style
multi-level marketing scheme which he
definitely was doing
um but like I I did the entry point into
that because he was on this other like
17 year old fortnite streamer clicks
like his his stream because he was doing
the rounds he went to like Aiden Ross
yeah he went to clicks his stream he's
like going up against like these like 20
year old kids and just basically farming
Their audience of like dummies yeah yeah
like all these like 12 13 year olds were
like oh I love fortnite and then they
like oh this Andrew take guy he seems so
cool he's got a Bugatti and
basically he was like getting all of
them involved and invested in this like
[ __ ] thing he called Hustlers
University the MLM scheme and I saw that
and I was pissed off about it I was like
what the [ __ ] are you guys giving this
guy like you know a free promo like
you're not even asking for money this is
ridiculous
um at least get a cut so he was doing
that [ __ ] and then like that dude's
manager clicks his manager is a fan of
mine and he'd like hit me up on the DMS
he was like bro you want to come on the
stream oh so it just happened in the
moment and I was like I was like yeah I
want to do this I want to talk to this
[ __ ] and I had done a little bit
of research on him already like I knew a
little bit about him so I just went on
and I just started talking to him and
he's just like talking about like how
women can't drive and all this other
[ __ ] he was like I've been in the most
car accidents like well I mean Princess
Diana right like oh my God yeah she had
a driver though yeah a female a lot of
people
okay so then you guys yeah I was
watching the back and forth and you guys
are getting into it about the female
driving
yeah and I just like I I was like bro
there's not that's not how this works
like you can't just be like this is my
personal experience yeah you can't
personally experience you're away from
like you know [ __ ] that isn't true right
um but he tried to do that and then I
just asked him like because I knew that
he wasn't a flat earther because I'd
heard him talk about that already which
is surprising because he's like
everything else yeah he's into
everything else except for flatter okay
which is weird yeah um
so I was like do you think the Earth is
round and he's like yeah I do so I was
like all right well do you think you
know the Earth is round because it feels
like it's flat and your personal
experiences would show that it's flat
like maybe empirical evidence is
important for that reason like maybe
science is important he was like no I
actually went up to the sky like I
literally was like what did you fly in a
[ __ ] rocket ship to the moon and see
it personally that the Earth is not flat
he's like yeah I did that that's right I
kind of like that I love that I love
that perfect but at that point he had
been like so thoroughly bullied by me
that like he was kind of like sinking
Alias for sure yeah yeah he was like
sinking into his [ __ ] seat he like
took off his headphones at a certain
point to not respond to me wow yeah
um so after that he was like he was not
as invested in like twitch uh and then
and then everybody started making like
videos about that
and also uh all the other [ __ ] that I
had like addressed there but people were
like researching yeah what the [ __ ] this
guy's about because he blew up out of
nowhere yeah like he's been around he's
been on the internet for a long ass time
I think he dated like Jordan Peterson's
daughter and [ __ ] which you know that's
kind of a dub
s like Caleb Peterson is [ __ ] she's
hot yeah you're into it I think she
probably her sweat glands are probably
busted from just eating straight raw
meat yeah
there's no diet there's no way she has
normal poops what do you think they're
like it's just like a fossil you're like
it's just a [ __ ] dense
take you're not pushing that that's a
little emasculating too you go on a date
you get a [ __ ] Pokeball and then she
just she just gets a steak
though you know very attractive woman
very attractive woman
um
very attractive yeah
except like I said like if I ate that
much meat I love meat like I eat a lot
of meat if I ate that much meat if I had
a meat only diet like I feel like I'll
be sweating [ __ ] straight grease you
know what I mean have you tried it
though I have not oh no I could tell you
try it yeah 100 kind of like Hustler's
University that's also true you'll learn
something you joined you might have
learned really how to not get 50 of the
money if you sign up because I've been a
member are you an affiliate code yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's great it's a great
business it's never been done before
it's very unique now if Jordan Peterson
was your father-in-law uh-huh right
um
like how would how would Thanksgiving do
they have Thanksgiving in uh Canada I
think they they have like a Canadian
they have a different Thanksgiving yeah
I don't know what is there it's like a
different day they're thankful for the
fact that uh they're next to America I
think
that was actually a very good holiday
um now now do we think that you guys
could reach common ground on certain
things nothing nothing Hassan you would
both agree that nothing Michaela's
beautiful that's true that is true we
both think that she's hot there it is
there you go that's one that's one and
that's it I like eating meat too so
there's that too but right I don't know
socialism yeah she's not a dude he
actually was a part of this socialist he
wasn't good when he was younger he was
literally a part of the NDP uh he was
like a student organizer for that what
happens like the leftist party there
yeah as he got older he went away from
it maybe that would happen to you yeah
no I do yeah socialism now
um no I think he just uh
I mean I think he just became older and
a lot of people don't really you know a
lot of people don't really follow
through on that especially when they're
younger if they got into it they see it
as like a fad rather than like something
to internalize or or truly understand